on va rajouter une seule chose c'est
juste un tout petit peu d'eau pour
éviter que ça brûle ici la recette toute
simple d'une huile de noix 100% vierge
pour deux kilos de cerneaux vous obtenez
un litre de cette huile dont les noix
ont été récoltés dans la région et cette
entreprise du loir-et-cher ouvre ses
portes pour expliquer aux consommateurs
sa chaîne de conception toute
fabrication est faite sur le site de
toute façon doit être validée par le
laboratoire aussi bien dans les
caractéristiques chimiques comme de
l'acidité ou des peroxydés chose de
laboratoire mais on va aussi le valider
d'un point de vue organoleptiques c'est
à dire qu'on va coûter l'huile et on va
valider ou non par exemple ici on a un
lot de l'huile de noisette qui a été
validé par le laboratoire et c'est un
lot de l'huile de noisette est en cours
de validation est ici l'usiné fier de
son processus zéro déchet et ses restes
de noix pressé par exemple sont
transformés en farine pour boulanger
d'autre part talent usine de
méthanisation du zoo de beauval
après la visite place à la dégustation
j'ai surtout apprécié la noisette
pourquoi le goût le jeu c'est vrai mais
elle m'a plu par contre la cacahuète
j'ai moi mais face aux consommateurs
l'entreprise ne s'en cache pas certains
de ces produits proviennent de
l'étranger comme la cacahuète importés
de chine
il ya des productions qui n'existe pas
en france malheureusement la cacahuète
on a très très peu de production en
france j'en avais fut un temps dans les
landes on a d'autres produits comme ça
comme la pistache c'est on n'a pas de
pistage de france encore aujourd'hui ou
du moins suffisamment importantes pour
pouvoir produire de l'huile et en
attendant l'huile de pistache il existe
déjà de lui deux pignons de pin la plus
chère ici comptez tout de même 100 euros
le litre